Speaker 1: I want to share a story with you
that really had me cracking up when I was
reading it this morning. You guys may know
about Fox News host Maria Bartiromo. I've
talked about her before, and for me, one of the
most interesting things about Maria Bartiromo,
who now is just a total pro-Trump propagandist on
Fox News and Fox Business, is that she used to be
a really good reporter when I was in my teens and
started following the stock market and casually
getting into trading stocks and whatnot, I would
watch CNBC. I thought I was cool watching CNBC
and Maria Bartiromo would be on there, and she'd
be reporting from the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange first woman to do so, doing really good
interviews with CEOs, holding people accountable,
asking tough questions. And she was really
a very interesting journalist and reporter.
And over the last few years, either because
of something that happened mentally or because
she really liked the idea of being in Trump's good
graces and having direct access to a president or
whatever, she became an uncontrolled,
unflinching, pro-Trump brown nosing sycophant.
And it turns out that it's not just a character
that she plays on the air. There is. There are
new revelations from this upcoming Jonathan Karl
book. We've told you about the book already,
and there are many interesting revelations in it
that she actually spoke to Donald Trump's former
attorney general, William Barr, on the phone
and went nuts on him about supposed voter fraud
committed by Democrats to steal the election
from Donald Trump. She really seems to believe
the stuff I want to read through some of the
allegations outlined here. New book alleges
Fox's Maria Bartiromo shouted at Bill Barr about
imagined voter fraud. This is crazy. These are
crazy allegations. Former Attorney General
Bill Barr says Fox News host Maria Bartiromo
called him up screaming about imaginary voter
fraud, according to his account in a new book
Betrayal by ABC's chief Washington correspondent
Jon Karl. Highlights Bartiromo is damaging role
as promoter of reckless lies about the election In
the books book, which comes out today, Karl writes
that quote Bartiromo had once been a widely
respected, trailblazing financial journalist.
Here's the things I said. She was the first
television reporter to report live from the
floor of the New York Stock Exchange. Now she had
her own show on Fox News, and she was using it to
boost a series of unfounded allegations designed
to overturn a presidential election. As President
Donald Trump frequently praised her, granted
her interviews OK. On Sunday, November eight,
one day after Fox and all the major networks said
Joe Biden was president elect, Bartiromo used her
Sunday show on the network to highlight the most
outlandish allegations of election fraud through
an interview with Sidney Powell. Remember Sidney
Powell that completely cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
attorney? Powell delivered a a fever rant, Carle
wrote, and Bartiromo didn't express or express one
ounce of skepticism. It was all a lie, he wrote.
But Sidney Powell is deranged. Theories would
have never taken hold if there weren't people in
positions of power and influence who had promoted
them. People like Maria Bartiromo, Bartiromo comes
up several times in betrayal in mid-November,
according to the book. Bartiromo called Barr to
complain that the DOJ hadn't done anything to stop
the Democrats from stealing the election. Listen
to this! She called me up and she was screaming,
Barr told Carl on the record. I yelled back at
her, She's lost it. Can you imagine the gall of
calling up the attorney general and saying, you're
not doing anything to stop this voter fraud,
which doesn't exist, of course. Carl said he
reached out to Bartiromo for a response because,
after all, it's highly inappropriate for
a journalist to call the attorney general
and demand he do something related to a criminal
investigation. Bartiromo did not respond,
but a Fox News spokesperson did get back to me
and denied Barr's account of the conversation on
Bartiromo behalf. Through the Fox spokesperson,
Bartiromo claimed Barr was the aggressive one,
yelling and cursing during the call
while he'd be justified in doing so.
If Maria Bartiromo is calling you up
and saying, What the hell are you doing?
Fox reiterated the same statement in a
response to a CNN business inquiry on Sunday.
Later in the book, Karl described Barter Romo's
program as a shortcut to Trump, saying that Powell
had a reliable platform that ensured she
could speak directly to the president. Powells
interviews with Bartiromo cut Trump's attention
and gave her a direct line to the White House.
What an insane situation that Trump White House
was in those last few months. It was a crazy
administration throughout, but in particular, once
the election took place and once it became clear
that Joe Biden was going to be the next president,
all the stops were pulled out. All all hell broke
loose. Trump having off the record meetings
specifically to circumvent presidential records
rules, Fox reporters calling up the attorney
general and demanding that they investigate
something that a reporter thinks they can tell the
attorney general to do. Lawyers like Sidney Powell
using the media to try to speak to Donald Trump
because Donald Trump is known to watch TV all day,
every day, just a complete. It's almost like a
childish romper room of sorts. It's hard to even
know how to describe it. And of course, wrapped up
in all of this are all sorts of possible potential
crimes, many of which are being investigated in
Georgia by the Southern District of New York,
maybe at the federal level. And hopefully, we'll
find out even 10 percent of it. I continue to
think that actually the further we get from
the Trump presidency, the more a lot of this
stuff is going to be buried, and we're never
really going to know the full scope of it.